[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sport rapports
dem sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers mein name ist andreas und
näher
ich bin selbst heeressportler und heute
zu gast beim sport report
siebenkämpferinnen und frisch gebackene
sportlerin des jahres ivona dadic
herzlich willkommen gratuliere auf jeden
fall nochmal gleich zu beginn zu deinem
neuen triumph etwas den nici bekommen
gemeinsam mit dem neuen sportler des
jahres dominic thiem wie war das für
dich diese trophäe entgegennehmen zu
dürfen also sehr sehr schön und ich
fühle mich wirklich sehr geehrt vor
allem wenn man sich die liste der
vergangenen preisträger anschaut muss
man sich geehrt fühlen da oben zu stehen
den preis entgegen nehmen zu dürfen
und umso schöner ist jetzt was auch ich
meinen namen auf dieser liste setzen
darf du warst ja schon einige male an
nominiert und auch weiter vorne in den
top rankings in den letzten jahren jetzt
hat heuer geklappt hast du damit
gerechnet nach deinen leistungen heuer
mit den starken performance video
gezeigt hast oder war es doch bis zum
letzten moment zittern für dich
angerechnet wie gar nicht damit also
natürlich wenn man dann unter top 3 ist
wünscht man sich dann natürlich auch
schon sehr aber genauso wie zu anderen
sportlerinnen ja auch das war aber so
dass ich sage ich mache mir da wenig
gedanken dazu man kann es nicht
beeinflussen beeinflusst hat man es dass
man einfach dort ist mit der sportlichen
leistung und alles andere haben dann die
sportjournalisten gemacht haben
vorgenommen den abend zu genießen
und wo ist dann halt eben kurz davor war
das quasi die wahl zur sportlerin des
jahres kommt da werden dann schon ein
bisschen nervös geworden und auch mein
trainer und mein freund damit waren da
hat man schon gemerkt ok jetzt ist die
situation ein bisschen angespannt und
umso schöner war es wie es dann ja wie
ich dann meinen eigenen namen gehört
habe
ich kann mir vorstellen dass das ein
unglaublich schöner moment ist und das
hast du heuer in einem komplett
wahnsinnigen ja indem sie eine
geschaffte nicht so dass wahrscheinlich
geplant war ist das so eingetreten wie
du es geplant hat das olympische spiele
anderer großer wettkämpfe du dir
vorgenommen hast du trotzdem hast du ein
ganz stark ist ja gezeigt dass einmal
revue passieren
wie die erste nachricht das glaubt uns
gekommen ist die ersten verschiebungen
wie die gekommen sind wie es dir damit
gegangen ist ja es war für mich
eigentlich grundsätzlich ein bisschen
schwierigeres jahr nicht nur wegen
corona sondern auch weil ich mich ja
letztes jahr bei der wm verletzt hatte
2009 10 am oberschenkel ich im ersten
moment dann doch die verletzung ist
nicht so schlimm und wir sind eigentlich
nur mal gut davon gekommen
in weiter was dann so dass ich ziemlich
lange dranhängt bin also war dann der
nerv beleidigt etwas abbekommen hat
eigentlich recht lang dauerte fast halb
so habe ich mir das in griff bekommen
haben teilweise wirklich verzweifelt
noch gar nicht gewusst wie geht es jetzt
weiter wird es funktionieren dann kommt
der doktor nur dazu und corona so quasi
noch einmal ein rückschlag für mich und
dann aber man braucht es jetzt ganz
anders in dem diesellok dann her dass
sie wirklich an den sachen arbeiten die
man heute eben in dieser verletzung
verloren gang hasan habe dann wirklich
aus diesem lockt dann sowas kurz gemacht
ich bin anzukommen training und war viel
stärker als vor dem lock down und habe
dieses ganze training das sie vielleicht
verloren habe wirklich noch winken also
habe dann die zeit da haben wirklich
nutzen wie vor eine karte profi kraft
gemacht ich bin vor einer kammer usd was
ich heute durch die verletzung nicht
machen konnte
ich bin im training gestartet und
philipp war wirklich überrascht wenn man
wirklich technik trainieren können
ein bisserl zu hause improvisiert ist
auch in seiner bisserl daneben gegangen
aber es war dann wirklich dann selbst
überrascht wie schnell das ghana ist das
eigentlich meine leistungen wieder von
bastheim und damit bewusst ok jetzt ist
alles möglich das an die olympischen
spiele schon abgesagt worden
das war für mich dann irgendwo im ersten
moment das warten was jetzt passiert wir
haben wirklich trainieren kann die
wahrheit verletzt habe doch eigentlich
viel training verloren und ich muss man
ehrlich sagen war dann schon erleichtert
wie die spiele abgesagt worden sein
obwohl im sommer sicher in form gewesen
wäre hätte es die spiele gegeben aber im
sommer dann trotzdem erleichtert weil er
einfach gesagt okay konnte es ja
wirklich extra noch einmal nutzen um
einfach auch die technik und die
körperliche fitness auch wenn nicht das
level zu bringen und dass du die form
gehabt dass das heißt ja dann bewiesen
mehrmals dass jetzt der filmer wind das
ist ein trainer war er in der zeit für
dich auch eine wichtige stütze dass du
weißt der die planung die sie in guten
händen
du kannst dich darauf verlassen dass
alles
gute abläuft auch jetzt mit der
verschiebung der olympischen spiele mit
einer verletzung dass das alles gut
hinkommt welchem faktor spielt dass sein
trainer als athletin in der performance
entwicklung ja eine sehr große rolle
mit dem philipp eigentlich
ununterbrochen kontakt und es war so
dass er eigentlich von anfang an da
zuversichtlich war dann wie es aber zeit
gegeben hat wo wirklich nichts weiter
als ich habe teilweise über meine sitzen
können nur laufen weil dieser nerv
teilweise auf der beleidigt war
jetzt hat einfach wirklich ganz ganz
schlecht ausgeschaut und dort sondern
kurzen moment gehen wir als ok wir
kriegen das allerdings im griff wo ihr
dann auch wirklich gesagt ob philipp
keine ahnung wenn das nicht geht ist
geht sich her einfach nimmer aus der
krimi wie das geht sie auf jeden fall
aus und es ist immer so gewesen wenn ich
an mir gezweifelt habe ob wir jetzt zu
wenig trainiert aber das kommt immer auf
einem großen bedenken habe ich gemerkt
habe ich mich nur auf das verlassen
können dass der philips so gut geplant
hat weil sie immer genug getan habe und
es war das jahr hat man wirklich dann
die angst wie man der dotzheimer bisserl
hat durch diese verletzung und die ist
dann einfach das zeigen will was man
kann und die olympischen spiele sind ja
das große ziel für mich und da war er
eigentlich immer der werkzeuge ok bleibe
ruhig das geht sie aus wie es dann
abgesaugt worden seien oder ziemlich
genau es ist trotzdem passiert irgendwie
alles mit irgendeinem grund und er
gesagt das ist ein grund ist extra und
auch wirklich das beste draus und ob der
zeitpunkt habe einfach vollgas geben und
dann war sie im sommer im endeffekt auch
ausgegangen also hat er von anfang an
wirklich recht gehabt
du hast eine jahresbestleistung dann
geschafft auch kuriose leistungen wie
den siebenkampf in einer stunde sehr
sehr erfolgreiche zu absolvieren
wie war der sommer dann als es dann bei
dir gut ging und du gesehen hast du da
geht mehr
ich bin gut drauf wie hast du das
gesehen ja also dieser stunden 7 km
feier sehr spezielles war an diesem tag
wo die spiele nächstes jahr anfangen und
habe so was da vorne noch nie gemacht
ich muss ehrlich sagen
im nachhinein gesehen war es wirklich
echt hardcore also wenn er zurückdenkt
es war echt einer der ersten wettkämpfe
weil er einfach man geht körperlich
wirklich an die grenzen also da ist
wirklich nimmer vorgang aber es war
richtig coole erfahrung der wettkampf
war wahnsinn und im endeffekt dann
diesen weltrekord aufzustellen in dieser
stunde und
so viele punkte zu sammeln die wir dann
im endeffekt selber überrascht von 800
also es ist ja alles so schnell gegangen
war keine bewusste viele punkte oder sie
machen bis zum philippe senderos muss
jetzt laufen also 6000 punkte marke sagt
wie man es ist jetzt und ist nach was
brauchen wir 6000 punkte und also ich
wieder auf 62 63 wahrscheinlich und
manchmal auch das gibt es gar nicht und
ja dann ist er wieder recht schnell
gegangen also wenn man glaube ich nur
mehr 30 sekunden kommt dass man beim
starten bevor die zeit ausläuft also ein
bisschen stressig und ja die erfahrung
von dem wirt kommt war einmalig und dann
aber doch wenn ihr diesen einer stunde
wenn du zwei tage zeit muss ja einfach
viel mehr drauf
diese sohn ist dann einfach eigentlich
von wettkampf zu wettkampf immer besser
geworden
und ja leider war das wetter es ist
überhaupt nicht auf meiner seite also
wir haben das schlechteste wetter kommt
bei dem ich jemals irgendwann wird kampf
machen können also schlecht aber als
wirklich es hat nur schnell kennen oder
schlechter gewesen oder nichts aber
wirklich wir haben so ein schlechtes
wetter com 15 grad dauerregen und es hat
wirklich es hat geschüttet
ununterbrochen daneben alleingang diese
punkte zu machen hat schon zeigt was er
drauf gehabt hab auch wenn die punkte
vielleicht nicht das waren was sie drauf
guckt ob bei konsum von dem wettkampf
wenn ihr dort 200 punkte dazu die wahl
ist auf jeden fall bei guten bedingungen
mit ein bisschen konkurrenz realistisch
gewesen
einsamer bei 6.600 plus das wäre für
mich persönlich eine neue bestleistung
gewesen und schon eine ordentliche marke
und damit auch etwas worum immer vorne
mitmischt und vorne mit dabei bist
solltest dich auch international messen
sollen beim diamond league meeting in
brüssel
dazu ist es dann aber nicht gekommen und
das ist immer so ein beherrschendes
thema das die gesamte zeit über während
wird die diese pandemie haben dass man
das sportler versucht so vorsichtig wie
möglich zu sein und ja nicht irgendwie
dass es da eine infektion kommt und dann
hat es doch einen positiven test wie war
das für dich dass es dann doch zu einem
positiven test gekommen ist die saison
wirklich mega gut und dann der
saisonabschluss mit der diamond league
der erste diamond league start für mich
als mehrkämpfer ist es wirklich
schwierig in einer diamond league rein
zu kommen weil man muss sich gegen
spezialisten messen oder ja es ist nicht
ganz so einfach gegen wen zu
laufen oder springen der halt nur dies
trainiert das sieben kämpfer und für
mich weil es einfach wirklich so quasi
noch einmal ein highlight im jahr und
immer wirklich mega drauf kreide war
richtig gut da eine frau im auto am weg
nach wien dass man weg nach brüssel und
habe ein corona test machen müssen
einfach um sicher zu gehen und weil wir
an der bubble gekommen und hatte alle
die da athlet machen müssen dass man
halt eben negativ ist und dann rufen wir
die ansagen gewinn positiv im ersten
moment gesagt es gibt zu denen gesagt
bitte schaut nochmal nach da muss
irgendwie weil ich fühle mich eigentlich
recht gut und dann haben sagt nein
wirklich positiv und habe dann haben
vermissen und trainer angerufen und er
hat 16
mit sowas macht man kann spaß unser
gefühl ich bin wirklich positiv und ja
dann bin ich haben gewonnen und wir uns
gar nicht verstanden weil gerade halt
eben in dieser wettkampfphase war
eigentlich relativ viel alleine in sankt
pölten haben wirklich geschaut einfach
ja mich zu diskreditieren einfach von
den leuten und weg zu halten um einfach
solche sachen zu vermeiden und hat
wirklich auf geachtet also wir sind da
wirklich einer philipp müssen sagen das
habe ich wirklich vorsichtig und wo sie
mir dann im endeffekt die stadt ist so
schwierig zu sagen als in meinem umfeld
waren alle negativ bis auf mich und wir
haben dann echt lange überlegt aber das
gute ist ich habe wirklich keinen
verlauf gehabt ihr war bis zum schluss
fit das war das positive an dem ganzen
zusätzlich aber es war dann nicht der
saisonabschluss den ich mir gewünscht
hätte
das ist das gängige vorstellung es zeigt
auch wie trotz aller vorsicht und gerade
als sportlerin und athleten sind wir das
sehr sehr vorsichtig und doch kann es
passiert aber gut dass du einen guten
verlauf hat das gesund geblieben bist
trotzdem infektion und dann
wahrscheinlich in die wohlverdiente
pause gegangen bist du hast du die
verbracht ja die ersten zehn tage in
quarantäne
da werde ich ein bissel gebraucht das
ist ein einfacher arbeiter
eigentlich war bei der diamond league
wissen ich habe mich fit gefühlt und
dann bin ich da haben meine filme in so
quasi eingesperrt gewesen und ich war ja
irgendwo ist mal gut gegangen also das
heißt ich habe mir nicht schlecht oder
gut gefühlt aber genau ich habe dann
einfach gesagt okay sich so kann froh
sein dass ich gesund bin dass es mir
nicht schlecht geht und das war dann
viel wichtiger wieder ist das ist
okay bin nicht der fan und kommentiert
staaten noch diesen zehn tagen wieder
herausgekommen bin ist mein urlaub
losgegangen
ja ich habe mir dann einfach die zeit
genossen gesagt aber jetzt werden auch
mal energie tanken für das nächste
wichtige ja du bist du bist jetzt auch
wieder im training
wie gestaltet sich jetzt das jahr in
richtung tokio 20 20 aber eben 21
stattfinden ist hat doch auch wieder
unsicher wettkämpfe wird wahrscheinlich
wenige geben die jetzt schon fixiert
sind wie gehst du damit um
ich bin jetzt wieder im training die
vorbereitungen 20 21 hat begonnen
unser heil person würde mit der jener
staaten mit einem hallen groß eigenes
anfang märz geplant wie das ganze sich
jetzt entwickelt müssen wir auf uns
zukommen lassen
ich glaube das ist national schon
einiges geben wird also ich muss schon
sagen unser verband hat wirklich große
arbeit geleistet in diesem sommer wir
haben echt genug wettkämpfe gehabt also
die aber auch ein grund warum ich so
gute leistungen bringen konnte waren
diese guten wettkämpfe demag opdam und
ich muss ehrlich sagen muss dass athlet
natürlich hat man das im hinterkopf dass
es sein können dass die spiele nicht
stattfinden
aber ich bin zuversichtlich muss ich
auch sein weil es wird einfach mein
training auch negativ beeinflussen wenn
jetzt jeden tag mir gedanken auch dass
das vielleicht gar nicht stattfindet und
von dem her ist es für mich im
terminkalender schon eingeplant oder
eingeschrieben sogar und für mich gibt
es nichts anderes wie die olympischen
spiele nächstes jahr genauso gehe in
jedes training positiv mit voller
energie und motivation und arbeit auf
die sie was immer erwünscht
was wäre dann das was du dir wünsche ich
mir natürlich du hast das auch schon
immer wieder gesagt man weiß dass du
auch die eine top-platzierung vorstellt
ist aber was wird jetzt konkret sagen
ist das ziel für nächstes jahr das ziel
ist einfach gesund zu bleiben also
gesund sein ist die wichtigste
voraussetzung für jeden sportler für
jeden menschen aber für uns sportler
ich möchte einfach fit sein image gut
trainieren und dann werde ich die in
tokio hoffentlich einer sehr sehr guten
form stehen und dank einer bislang
klickt dazu wenn dies alles
zusammenpasst an die zwar druck dann
glaube ich es ist wirklich realistisch
von dem was ich von klein auf schon
träume mir dort wirklich einen traum zu
erfüllen mit einer olympia-medaille
genau aber ich sage immer im vorhinein
viel über olympia allen zu reden macht
wenig sinn weil es seit dann
immer im sport war es immer vielleicht
auch etwas kummer kann als man glaubt
von dem her ist es wichtig hat zu
trainieren und dann werden wir abliefern
und dann wird sie das andere von alleine
ergeben und das duo für diesen traum
hielt das beweist nicht nur jetzt
sondern du hast ja auch schon im laufe
seiner karriere und nicht nur viel
gewonnen sondern auch viele schritte
gesetzt um immer besser zu werden zum
beispiel was in england und hat dort mit
den weltbesten trainiert das ist schon
einige jahre her aber das war sicher für
deine entwicklung auch enorm wichtig was
hast du da in der zeit für dich und
deine karriere mitnehmen können
ich bin ja als 18 jährige dann nach
england gegangen nachdem wie für die
spieler haben bis 2012 war für mich das
highlight war zu dieser zeit und habe
dann die möglichkeit direkt seite an
seite von der olympiasiegerin von damals
zu trainieren und das 18 jahre athletin
felix nicht wieder sagt das mache das
finde ich cool ihr als vorbild gesehen
und so eine chance zu bekommen war halt
einfach einmalig und bin ja eben noch
england und behinderte in einem system
gekommen weil sie einfach nicht gewohnt
war von der haar als sie war 18 habe
trotzdem noch nicht so viel trainiert
und vor allem leider zweimal mit einer
knieverletzung verletzt musste beide
male operiert werden
von dem er ist so dass ein bisschen das
negative von dort aber was ich nehm
wirklich viel positives mit je gesehen
dass in wahrheit die ahnung mit wasser
kochen und habe gesehen wie es dann halt
quasi in der allgemeinen klasse wirklich
läuft für mich selber viel dazu gelernt
mich weiterentwickelt selber auf die
beine gestellt zu werden dort und ich ja
warum sein leben selbst zu kümmern und
bekommen eigentlich sehr viel mitnehmen
und hätte sie schon als 18-jährige
widerwillig es natürlich wieder machen
aber ich bin richtig froh wieder in
österreich zu sein
mein umfeld hier zu haben ein team
gefunden zu haben und es war die beste
entscheidung wieder nach hause zu gehen
aber es zeigt auch dass du eine art hass
auch mit mit niederlagen oder mit
rückschlägen umzugehen
woher kommt das dass du da diese art es
dass du auch in den vermeintlich
schlechteren dingen oder ein
verletzungen
das was trotzdem etwas gutes zu sehen
und die positiven erfahrungen sich auf
die zu fokussieren wo er glaubt so kommt
das wirtschaftsstarke sagen auch von
meinen eltern die ja vom balkan kriegen
nach österreich gekommen sind und dann
habe ich sehr früh mein bruder verloren
beim motorradunfall und hierbei einfach
schon sehr bald gelernt mit in
schwierigen situationen mit denen
umzugehen und das beste daraus zu machen
und ich glaube maintal kann mich oder
auch im kabinett so leicht zurück
schlagen es gibt immer viel schlimmeres
via kleine verletzung oder größere
verletzung im leben
und dann hat einfach einen rückhalt wie
meine familie zu haben wo ich gesagt
okay kann ich mich verlassen egal was
passiert macht mir einfach so stark und
über die jahre macht man im sport auch
einiges mit und wird abgehärtet uni wird
sagen ich habe schon einiges
durchgemacht von dem er bringt mich
nicht so schnell was dem konzept wenn
man wirklich will natürlich mit einem
guten team und einem umfeld von ärzten
und physik an man immer wieder
zurückkommen muss einfach haben sich
zurückkämpfen das ist nicht so einfach
aber es geht auf jeden fall
und das heißt auf jeden fall bewiesen
und ist jetzt dass jetzt auch deine
familie angesprochen und merkt auch dass
du sehr familien verbunden ist welche
rolle spielt eine familie für den fall
auf deiner karriere aber auch für deine
leistungen die du dann am tag xr bringst
ja eine sehr große rolle also meine
familie unterstützt mich von tag 1 und
wenn man beim wettkampf dabei ist wo ich
am start bin sieht man immer mindestens
zehn bis fünfzehn heute meiner familie
ob das jetzt meine eltern sind oder
meine
wandten die wirklich zuschauen kommen
und nicht wirklich voll so button
wie immer wenn die stadien leer ist aber
familie da ist reicht mir das
anzuschauen und es gibt irgendwie so
extra motivation wird so quasi zu laufen
und auch bei diesen stunden mehrkampf
der wangler wie gefühlt es war riesen
familie 30 bis 40 leute von uns da und
das war einfach cool leaf tribüne zu
sehen ist zu sehen wie stolz dass hinter
sich eben dort unten laufen und gibt mir
einfach diese extra kraft dass er vorher
seine mentale stärke angesprochen
glaubst du dass das etwas ist wo du auch
anderen gegenüber einen großen vorteil
hast du auch der weltspitze vielleicht
gegenüber
da das finden kannst ich glaube es gibt
sicher schon auch athleten die ist eine
mentale stärke haben wie ich aber ich
habe das immer wieder von meinen trainer
die sagen ich würde mir wünschen dass
unsere andere athleten also mental stark
werden weil es ist schon teilweise bei
mir wenn sie im training hat durch
dieses viele training dass wir haben es
läuft manchmal nicht das heißt die leute
dann bei 150 ununterbrochen runter war
es ja nicht so gut ist bei einer
bestleistung von 1 87
und dann kommt der wettkampf nicht
funktioniert einfach dann springe auf
einmal wieder bestleistungen und es ist
einfach dass sie meine leistung einfach
abrufen kann ich kann auch das vertrauen
was ich trainiert habe und dann einfach
mental so stark bin das ist ok lass mir
doch nicht aus dem konzept bringen
ihr macht das jahrelang der sitzt das
muss dass muss ich können und wenn es
darauf ankommt bin ich eigentlich schon
immer da
das heißt diese sicherheit zu haben aus
dem täglichen training was für viele
glaube ich nicht so greifbar ist und
auch für mich immer so oftmals seien ein
mysterium wie siebenkämpferinnen es
schaffen an sieben tagen die woche das
training in den verschiedensten
disziplinen unterzubringen wie kann man
sich deinen trainingsablauf vorstellen
wie schaffst du es in all den
disziplinen so gut wie möglich zu werden
vor allem auch weil die disziplinen
dabei sind die sich in dem sie eine
beißen ja nicht unbedingt gut zusammen
funktionieren wie schafft man das
wir haben sieben wochentage sechs
trainingstages ein tag davon
das ist meistens der sonntag ist bei uns
ruhetag und da müssen wir einfach
schauen dass man diese sieben
disziplinen unter diese sechs tage
packen das macht man eigentlich mein
trainer immer der plant mir die woche so
gut wie es geht natürlich ja es ist dann
schon schwieriger sie
kämpfer wenn man sich vorstellt ich
würde nur einer disziplin trainieren
dann habe ich halt haider intensives
training mombasa bei amberg einfach geht
das nicht der hat jeden tag wirklich
intensives training wir haben dann einen
tag in der woche wo man bis herunter
gehen weil sonst wird es gab einfach
wirklich nicht aushalten
du hast wirklich beinhart trainieren
durchziehen
teilweise war ein interview auf stoff
wenn wir zwei also wirklich das ist
unglaublich das tut mir alles weh auch
als leistungssportlerin aber deswegen
diesmal als mehrkämpfer glaube ich immer
im besten alter bisschen später weil er
einfach man die chance auch nicht hat
eine blinde öfter als einmal in der
woche zu trainieren und ja viel arbeit
viel regeneration natürlich auch und
einfach anschauen
7-zip lienen eine woche zu packen gibt
es lieblingsdisziplinen die man dann hat
oder einfach dinge die man lieber und
gerne und öfter trainiert oder hat man
alle das 17 gleich lieb also es gibt
lieblingsdisziplinen aber nachdem ihr
siebenkämpferin bin ist das meine
lieblingsdisziplin und jeder disziplin
die ich trainiere ist wichtig weil sie
punkte bringt aber wenn ich mir jetzt
aussuchen könnte wäre es auf jeden fall
techniktraining also ich bin eher so im
techniktraining gesetzt danach im
endeffekt vielleicht körperlich ein
bisschen weniger anstrengend aber ich
bin ja eigentlich alles gern aber wenn
es manchmal weh klassen kennt wer dieses
training für die 800 es ist einfach
physisch das anstrengendste das kommt
immer am abend vor der wochen das ist
jeden samstag wenn ihr dann halt immer
sehr gute sonja wochen noch nicht
irgendwas super-wochenende training nun
aber ich mache wirklich alles gerne also
das muss echt sagen mir macht das
einfach spaß oder 800 er ist ja auch
dann im wettkampf letzte disziplin
stimmt das habe ich das korrekt im kopf
genau das ist der grünen der abschluss
dieser 800 meter also ich muss ehrlich
sagen wo sie hassliebe auch das training
am ortskern weil dieses training wenn
das gemacht das ist das beste gefühl der
woche wenn der ist dann fertig ist ist
da was mama hat was da und ja es ist
einfach ein unbeschreibliches gefühl
aber davor mit dem recht wünschen die
bahn freut oder ikone trainer und beim
mehrkampf ist genauso dieses gefühl vom
800 da bin ich nervös wie nie sonst also
wirklich da rede nix da ist meine
trainerin als der wahre ok jetzt ist
soweit
aber das gefühl dann wenn der
startschuss gefallen ist ist cool
maria
und schaut dass man es ins ziel bringt
was man meistens dann auch was man
ungefähr braucht um seine zielsetzung zu
erreichen oder die platzierung zu
erreichen kann man ungefähr im rennen
dann auch abschätzen wo man gegenüber
den konkurrentinnen steht oder geht das
im rennen gar nicht also international
ist es schon so dass man manchmal auch
taktisch läuft wenn jetzt so gerechnet
zumal medaille oder um einen gewissen
platz und war es mal war sie aber von
den beste leistung her wie schnell die
anderen athletinnen laufen
da war es mir an okimo sie vor der st
muss ich da hinten drauf bleiben oder
muss ich vorbei laufen oder muss sie
zwar drei sekunden vor sei um heute noch
einen platz gut zu machen oder eine
metalle abzusichern wie kann ich das
ganz leicht ausrechnen wenn ich sage ich
bin jetzt auf kurs 6500 punkte sagt
jetzt einmal was muss ich dafür laufen
und was du dir nicht laufen dass sie
nicht ausgeht und genauso wie im
training hat ja die uhr eine rolle 200
meter doch schaut man einfach mit und
man läuft mal läuft so und so immer das
was geht
aber es gibt dann schon auch taktische
rennen also das taktische rennen 2018
bei der weltmeisterschaft hat mir dann
auch einige punkte gekostet wir sind
viel zu langsam angelaufen
es wird irgendwie keiner viel geld haben
sie alle zu können wenn jeder sein blog
so quasi ob sich erweitert und im
endeffekt sonst an allen ein paar punkte
gekostet aber an der platzierung hat
sich nicht geändert und das war dann
eigentlich im ziel auch wieder egal aber
ich denke das schwierig vor wenn man
dann mitten im rennen weiß okay
die konkurrentin es gerade dort das
heißt dass wir das endergebnis also
dieses nachdenken mitten im rennen das
da stelle ich mir unglaublich blockiert
und vielleicht auch vor das passiert mir
bei der richtigen app camera aber sehr
faszinierend zu sehen wie das bei euch
abläuft was mir auch oder was allen
beobachtern und sportfans auffällt ist
dass wir ja nicht nur dich als
weltspitze
siebenkämpferin haben sondern mit zwei
seiner kolleginnen verena brenner und
sarah lager auch herr esser
sportlerinnen top athletinnen im
siebenkampf noch haben warum ist
österreich seine starke siebenkampf
nation tv geräte so aufgestellt wie was
ist sie wert
aber ich glaube einfach ich habe über
die jahre zeigt dass man im siebenkampf
wirklich weltklasse sein kann und dass
sie auch nach dem okay wenn die das kann
warum sollen wir das als kenner und mit
der varena wir schon ein konkurrent in
seit jahren werde jetzt einmal sagen die
verena hat jetzt in den letzten zwei
jahren wirklich einen
mega schritt nach oben gemacht die sarah
kommt so quasi von hinten nach diesen
ein bisschen jünger wie wir
ich glaube einfach unsere trainer und
sie darunter ein bisschen ausgetauscht
haben wolfgang adler und mein trainer
philipp haben sie da echt viel
ausgetauscht wir haben teilweise eine
trainingsgemeinschaft gehabt die man
dann zwar auch sehen aufgelöst haben ja
die haben einfach ihren eigenen weg
macht dann sind da ist ein weg nach oben
möglich haben den genutzt und ich glaube
das ist irgendwo ein bisschen zufall ist
dass es so gut läuft und natürlich auch
der verband der anhalt eben gesagt okay
diese fördern unsere trainer sind
angestellt dies alles zusammen glaube
macht uns drei mehrkämpferinnen aus oder
macht uns zu einem mehrkampf nation und
was auf jeden fall die richtung
vorgegeben und das erfolgreich wünschen
dir natürlich auch für die zukunft viel
gesundheit so wie du es gesagt hat aber
auch viel erfolg danke dass du beim
sport reporter ist und alles gute danke
auch an euch die heute wieder beim sport
report mit dabei war heute zu gast
gewesen
sportlerin des jahres ivona dadic und
wir freuen uns wenn ihr auch beim
nächsten mal wieder mit dabei seid
servus
[Applaus]
[Musik]